i've been using my iphone 12 pro max for
over two months now
and while i can say that this is my
favorite iphone yet
there are definitely a couple of
annoying issues with it
so in this video i'm gonna cover both
the good and the bad
with the goal of letting you know
whether it's worth buying
compared to one of the other iphone 12
models or if it's worth just waiting for
the next iphone
that's rumored to have some very
interesting changes
but before i talk about some of those
iphone 13 leaks and rumors
i want to get into my experience with
this 12 pro max
first off i've got to say that i love
the 6.7 inch display
being noticeably larger than the one on
the 11 pro max
helping it be super immersive for
watching videos
and playing games and basically
everything else
especially since the bezels are now
slimmer thanks to the new flat front
glass panel
the display quality is even better this
year with improved viewing angles
so it doesn't turn blue when you look at
it off axis
like you get with the 11pro max and in
terms of the speakers
they're now a bit louder and they have
brighter highs as well
which is great because i felt like the
11 was lacking that
and this helps when trying to listen to
a youtube video or a podcast
when you don't have any earbuds laying
around in terms of the actual size of
the new 12 pro max it's definitely quite
a bit larger
and while some people had issues with it
being too big i personally think that
it's
right on the edge of being too big but
not over the line
so it's still fine for me on top of that
the new flat edge design makes it easier
to hold in the hand
even though it feels thicker so it seems
that the square edges
offer more grip compared to any previous
iphone
these new completely flat sides
seriously make it feel
like a totally different phone since the
frame of every iphone for the last five
years has been basically the exact same
shape
so this one feels completely different
giving you a new
and fresh experience as far as the
performance the a14 bionic has been
great
feeling very snappy all the time and
basically every game or app i've tried
to run
has no issues at all being perfectly
smooth
however i honestly haven't noticed much
of an improvement
compared to my old 11 pro max and part
of the reason is the fact that the
iphone's design is now limiting the
performance
due to thermal throttling we know this
for a fact because the ipad air 4
comes with the same exact a14 bionic
chip
and that ipad actually gets much higher
graphics performance
compared to the 12 which shows that
apple turned
down the gpu clock speed so it wouldn't
have overheating issues
and very recently leaks and rumors point
to apple aggressively researching
vapor chamber thermal systems trying to
get it done
in time for the next iphone and i'm
almost
100 sure that they will because if they
don't
the graphics performance is gonna stay
the exact same
with the a15 chip and apple can't have
that
so i guess that's one reason to wait for
the next iphone
but even with limited performance the 12
pro max
is still faster than samsung's brand new
s21 ultra
and basically every single way i
personally think that at this point
display refresh rate is really what
makes your phone feel faster
not raw performance and unfortunately
we're still stuck with a static 60hz
display
and that's extremely disappointing for
an 1100
flagship phone especially since the s21
ultra can now use 120hz mode
while at full resolution i'm starting to
think that apple held off on that
feature on purpose
because they knew that 5g the new design
max safe and everything else would be
enough to get people to upgrade
and to be honest it was now before i get
into the new
magsafe wireless charging feature i want
to cover the controversial topic
of 5g and the experience that i had with
it over the past couple months
first off it's not just the new 5g
capability
the iphone 12s come with a new top of
the line modem from qualcomm
which also features much faster lte
as well this made a massive difference
in my basement
where my 11pro max always struggled with
getting service
and not only that but it was better at
random spots in my city as well
i previously had issues with youtube
videos buffering every once in a while
but now i rarely have the issue with my
12 pro max
even when not using 5g at all but in
terms of actual
5g data speeds we've never seen anything
like it even though we don't have
millimeter wave 5g in our city
my church has an office building where i
basically never had a decent cellular
signal
but now with the 12 pro max it's
perfectly fine
and about a month ago we were making
very long comparison videos
which ended up having huge file sizes
and hilariously it was faster to airdrop
the final file
to the iphone 12 go to the roof upload
it to youtube
then trying to upload it on our macs
using wi-fi
which is insane we did that on probably
10 different occasions when we were in a
crunch for time
so yes the new qualcomm chip and 5g
has actually been very helpful which i
wasn't expecting
however i have noticed that when my
phone is using 5g
the battery does drain a bit faster than
it did before
and in general i still feel that my old
11 pro max
had a little bit more battery life than
this one
but it's still more than enough to get
through the day and the rest of the new
features
including the new design definitely make
it a worthwhile trade-off
now moving on to max safe this is
actually one of the features that i was
really excited about
not for the wireless charging aspect but
for the possibility of awesome
accessories
that you magnetically attach to the back
of your iphone we recently did a video
where we looked at a few of the best
third-party mac safe accessories for the
iphone 12
and i was surprised by how well they
worked after just a couple of months
after release
one of those was this cheap little
aluminum stand that lets you insert your
existing max a wireless charger
and it simply holds your iphone in
mid-air while charging
with super fast 15 watt charging speed
so it's perfect for an office type job
like we have
but even more exciting than that are the
future magsafe accessories that we can
expect
like pop sockets that can be easily
taken off magnetically
to access wireless charging which fixes
the main
issue that popsockets have had forever
there's also some new battery packs that
hold on magnetically while wirelessly
recharging your iphone
which is incredible and i can't wait
till apple gives us an official version
of their smart battery case or the
battery add-on
so max safe has really been great so far
and i think it's only going to get
better in the future now i want to get
into the cameras
which has recently been a very strong
suit for apple the biggest complaints i
had with the cameras on the 11 pro max
were mostly software related night mode
was limited to only the main camera
which basically made taking selfies at
night useless
and same for any of the other rear
lenses but now
i can confidently use any lens i want
and i know i'll get a great picture at
night
especially now that you can take a night
mode portrait photo
which is my personal favorite because it
looks so good and for the daytime
apple continues to kill it with their
hdr
auto white balance and their colors the
new lidar scanner
greatly helps portrait photos turn out
much better
with more accurate depth mapping with
cleaner edges
lidar is also being used for video
autofocus as well
as you can see right here it catches
onto focus perfectly
every single time so apple has been
killing it with this new feature
and i absolutely love the new sensor
shift image stabilization
that's exclusive to the max model which
basically makes it look like i'm using a
gimbal
to get super smooth video but i'm
literally hand holding the phone
but with all of that said there are two
major issues
that really bugged me about the camera
on the 12 pro max
first off there's this really annoying
light reflection effect
that's very noticeable at night as you
can see here
the lights reflect inside of the image
and they can totally ruin video
as well as photos like this one of my
son
in front of the fireplace which has
glare right over him
the second issue i have is with the
telephoto lens
which is now a longer 2.5 x zoom but in
order to make it zoom more
apple had to raise the f-stop which
takes in less light
than the regular 12 pro's 2x zoom which
in turn
introduces noise especially when taking
portrait mode photos
because of that i found myself switching
to the main lens all the time
to take portrait mode photos so i
honestly wish that apple would have just
kept it the same
but other than that the cameras have
been amazing
and there are people sharing reviews of
the brand new galaxy s21 ultra
saying that the iphone 12 pro max still
has a bit of an
edge in the camera department so overall
my experience with the 12 pro max has
been awesome
but i'd honestly have to say that if you
don't care about having the biggest
display i would just go for the regular
iphone 12 pro
since it comes with the very convenient
six gigs of ram
which i did notice made a huge
difference now that my apps no longer
close randomly
and it also gets the better 2x zoom lens
but there's still one question to answer
should you go for a 12 pro model
or wait for the next iphone to come out
later this year
based on recent leaks the iphone 13 or
potentially the iphone 12
s is gonna come with a number of
advantages
like a vapor chamber cooling system
sensor shift stabilization coming to all
of the new models
finally a smaller notch 120 hertz
refresh rate
which is huge a touch id sensor under
the display
and potentially a new magsafe smart
connector
replacing the lightning port if any of
that is extremely important to you
then it might actually be worth waiting
another eight months
for the new iphones especially if you're
planning to keep it long term
so there you guys go that was my
long-term review of the iphone 12 pro
max
and if you enjoyed it go ahead and tap
the like button and click the circle
above to subscribe
and definitely check out one of those
two videos right over there especially
the iphone smart connector video
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one